This is Jack Nugen and you're watching
now you see it.
Let's talk about how the film inglorious
bastards is actually making fun of you.
Couldn't.
Tarantino is one of the most popular and
consistently violent mainstream
directors.
His films focus on people committing
violence.
Criminals who killed contract killers,
a black market gun runner who killed a
former assassin,
killing for revenge,
a special Walmart two unit who's one
goal is killing nets,
more contract killers.
And finally his newest film,
the hateful eight coming out fall 2015
we'll start Samuel L.
Jackson,
as you guessed it,
as contract killer.
There's no doubt that Terentino's films,
especially as higher budget ones display
this sort of hyper violence with
numerous and exaggerated deaths.
Vanity Fair made a nice chart telling
each duck in a tarantino film at how
that person died.
Showing just a file.
It is,
scopes can be Terentino's eighth till
inglorious bastards.
Ace,
no exception.
The film needs 57 killed,
not cleaning the 340 teeth deaths from
the fire.
And the fear at the end of the film is
averages to one kristen to death.
About every two and a half minutes.
No,
that's fine.
Even with all this violence,
inglourious basterds was a huge
financial and critical success earning
over $300 million in eight academy award
nominations.
The majority of Terentino's films did
well in the box.
In fact,
of the nine films,
charity Tino has directed eight have
earned a triple their original budget.
So what does it say about us,
the viewers who pay to see and enjoy
Terentino's films?
Do we like violence?
Is it wrong for us to enjoy movies where
people die left and right turn to,
you know,
realize is this chuck position and you
mean goes so far as to criticize us,
the viewers for finding hyper violence
in his,
yeah,
so entertaining.
Let's take a look at inglorious bastards
and see how we critique an audience that
glamorizes violence.
Inglorious bastards is about a World War
II special unit named the bastards whose
mission is to blow up a cinema where
dozens of high ranking Nazi soldiers in
the lead watcher I propaganda film,
including killer himself.
The film shown at the cinema is about
Friedrich solar and Nazi soldier who
single handedly kills 215 brushings from
a guard tower.
The film titled Nation's Pride is
extremely violent from what we see.
The film consist of little more than
shots of Friedrich's older shooting and
killing thousands of Russian soldiers.
The crowd of Nazis loves it.
They cheer and laugh at each step of
praising the film hill even tells the
director of the film,
this is your best film,
yet we can't help but look at the
audience watching nuisance priding find
them a bit humorous and ridiculous.
They do this repetitive,
tasteless and unnecessarily killing,
entertaining and well made.
To us.
It appears to be nothing but a cheap
spectacle movie.
But think about it.
It doesn't sound familiar.
The Nazi viewers or audience members
watching a film,
but so are we watching inglorious
bastards.
It's a film with NFL.
Don't we react with similar praise to
quint Terentino's hyper violence.
Psalms 20 where the audience members,
I want to suggest to the Terentino's is
trying to say us viewing inglorious
bastards is similar to the Nazis viewing
nation's pride.
We cheer a death even when it's
tasteless and glorifies unnecessary
violence.
We see just as much excessive violence
inglorious bastards as the Nazis do when
nations pri,
while the bastards are in the middle of
their plan to blow up the building,
the owners of the cinema in a separate
attack like the whole cinema on fire and
lock the exit doors so the Nazi crowd is
trapped in burnt alive.
Even though the bathrooms mission to
kill everyone in the cinema is
fulfilled,
they still shoot into the crowd of
Nazis.
More unnecessary violence and blogged a
cinema even more unnecessary violence.
There's ridiculous files throughout the
film.
People caught off scalps get beat to
death with baseball bats and get shot in
the testicles.
Both nation's pride and inglorious
bastards contain excessive violence.
Similarities don't stop.
They're both protagonists.
Carve Nazi symbols with a knife and are
overly faithful to their country.
Even the shots and nations private
inglorious bastards are similar.
Look at this shot of a person flying out
of the exploding cinema.
Notice the similarities between this
shot and these shots of soldiers falling
out of buildings during nation's pride
chair.
Tino is showing that his movie is not
far off from nation's pride.
Even the film titles are comparable
where inglorious bastards is the exact
opposite meaning of nations pri.
These films are similar,
so are their respective audiences.
US viewing inglorious bastards and the
Nazis viewing nations pri,
we both praise the violence in the film.
We both cheer on death.
We both get desensitized to the
brutality of it.
By comparing us to the Nazi viewers
Terentino's criticizing our love for
excessive violence.
We're a bunch of easy to please
dimwitted audience members who find
entertainment and senseless gruesome
killings in the same way that the Nazi
viewers are portrayed as simple minded
audience members find entertainment in
the over to top violence and nations
pride.
He's poking fun at us.
He's saying where as ridiculous as the
Nazi viewers are looking at other
instances of it sort violence and this
is by no means limited to include as
faster.
It's either Tarantino does this in all
of his other films as well.
He sometimes even use his death for
comedy.
I said
goodbye,
but I'm as you got to have an opinion.
I mean,
do you think that God came down from
Heaven and stop
an accident?
It takes skill to pawn audience into a
world where killing can make up a
punchline,
but there's more to it than that.
The screen desensitizes us.
We can remove ourselves from the
realities of death.
When we watch a film and terrence,
you don't knows it.
The extent we can see death as a joke
though is worth making fun of and
nations.
Pri provides a good allegory for how
ridiculous we can be.
Is it hypocritical that we can praise
violence in a film yet to announce it in
reality?
One final anecdote about the two films
and their audiences.
While nation's pride is playing shows,
sauna kills the real friedrich solar,
but nobody in the audience notices
because they're so engrossed in the
violence up to fill.
They think the gunshot noise is just
another sound effect is Tarantino making
your commentary about how we don't
address or notice deaths in reality and
only pay attendance to the ones in the
movies we adore.
Glorious bastards is not the only felt
to critique it's viewers,
which I need to film that features an
audience.
Consider if the directors making a
commentary about the audience actually
watching the film,
Wolf of Wall Street.
It's about the rise and fall of a
corrupt businessman named Jordan
Belfort.
He's unfaithful to his wife,
steals money from thousands of people,
has no one who truly loves him and
spends years in jail.
Logically,
we should look at Jordan Belfort as a
dishonest,
despicable man,
but look at the audience in the final
shot of the film.
Do they look like they despise him?
They adore him.
They want to be just like him,
rich and famous.
No matter how much dishonesty and
stealing it takes,
just like inglorious bastards.
The director of showing the flaws of us
as an audience is Jordan Belfort.
Really the type of person we should
strive to be like a clever director can
use audiences or even crowds of people
as a way of generalizing a society as a
whole.
It's most interesting.
However,
when the commentary is centered on the
viewers of the film who are far from
perfect.
So the next time you see any movie that
features an audience,
ask yourself,
are they making fun of me?
[inaudible].